more and more people from all sides are
going to sit there who are Democrats who
are Republicans who are whoever they're
going to say yeah you know what I don't
know man I'm just not I can't see this
thing making any sense you know what I'm
done I'm done with this there's going to
be more and more of that happening you
know what Patrick I agree with you and I
think a we got to be optimistic but more
there's actual evidence for this so I
get invited to speak at different places
including corporate you know situations
right and they're all very scared to
hear from me about this because I show
them this and I'm like this is what's
going on and they know it from the
inside anyway and the very few of them
will say anything publicly
privately they all agree they all know
they all know this the corporate people
the people who are running things
they've been bullied into this they're
afraid to speak up right we just got to
give them permission to do that by
seeing that it's not just the crazies
who are making these points there's some
reasonable people who want people of all
Races to to never be discriminated
against who want people to get along
right that's what I want I just want you
if you're good you get the job